this is Greg from LA as he relationship
advice hey what's up guys
Jesus Christ Greg and I'm looking for
some relationship advice so I just
started about two and a half months ago
dating a porn star
yes and she's smoking hot right she's
got long dark hair dark skin all natural
big tits big ass yeah pretty face just
like straight Tommy died she's 22 I'm 32
so there's a bit of an age gap but we're
really connecting inside and outside the
bedroom right so the pros she's really
fun to be around the sex is amazing
she's bringing home girls for me or
having like threesomes foursomes five
Sims we have planned this weekend girls
in five somes you're gonna get it
catered by Sims you better have elected
back in my bowl about 20 seconds to mind
Eric okay so the pros she's really fun
to be around the sex is amazing she's
bringing home girls for me or having
like threesomes foursomes five Sims we
have planned this weekend if people
steal your [ __ ] stuff too awesome
that scenario could be but on the flip
side of course you know you have to deal
with the jealousy and the insecurity of
having her have sex with other guys on a
regular basis you know train it up um
you know everything's clean I'm not
worried about that but it's more just
like like I said my jealousy my
insecurities like try to deal with it
internally we do things we talk about it
a lot our communication is on point and
she's really supportive with it so I'm
curious how you guys would handle it if
you could handle it what would you do
you know to deal with seeing other guys
on her social media - you know that
she's been sleeping with and just all
this type of stuff where you said she
can separate the emotional from the sex
and so far it's been pretty smooth well
I'm curious what you would do to be able
to like handle those internal emotions
everything you do love your show gang
gang poignant speaker probably one of
the more poignant yoandri had sent in a
video gregory's his name yes Greg from
LA shut up - greg 32 doing the damn
thing
um you want jump in this one first I at
32 he's had his fun so he's gonna be
open-minded could I deal with it
I don't know it also depends what you
want here's the other thing I'm sure
she's great
I'm off to the sex is off the charts is
it off the chart Uno's dude he's saying
that in a car he's off the charts here's
the other thing phi summed stress me out
dude oh i came and imagine it first of
all i don't know what it that's life
what it means you and two girls hooking
up and two other girls are stealing a
bunch of [ __ ] in your place that's what
that is
there's that if they're on the hustle or
you and two girls are hooking up and
then the other three girls just on the
sidelines ready to get into the game
it's so stressful dude yeah and you
better have more d'oeuvres
you better have electrolytes and there
better be drugs dude yeah it's a lot of
responsibility but that's not what this
is about
that's not what this is about don't tell
me that I don't know if I could deal
with it because here's the thing you're
32 brother I don't know if you want a
family you have one now you have five
[ __ ] women so family you Charles
Manson
what do you plan to do bro i I pray can
hammer just goes down the road it'd be
tough for your mom you know for your kid
to look up well what did mom do when she
was younger yeah turn on it's a [ __ ]
video you know I'm saying that well
Brandi enough to think about that you
could have think about them them having
sex on tape I don't think my people get
need Jaqueline on them well that's what
they got to do that's the big numbers
they don't have to they could just have
sex man a good four I like that he's
open-minded
I wouldn't be that just type if I was 32
also she's 22 and you don't have family
nothing to worry about no
responsibilities how fun dude
and also I'm assuming because she does
it for work and obviously just getting
railed you can do your own thing on the
side too
you're ruining this guy's life can we go
to the culture corner let's get some
suggestions from some people who were
probably smarter than us cat could you
handle it if your male is a porno star
mmm I think it depends cuz on one hand I
think if he's a porn star the last thing
he'd want to do when he gets home is do
anything sexually it's like working at a
strip club the last thing you want to do
is come home and then [ __ ] you be some
but yeah what I watched some of it the
other night actually the special yeah
man dude thanks one of my favorite parts
I've only watched about 20 minutes is
the acting in the beginning oh yeah
where I'd play all the characters bro
it's walking good dude
yeah dude God I thought about [ __ ] all
over me dude the acting that we're
getting this [ __ ] Craven I thought
that the blonde thought at the end was a
little much but he's hot
kind of cute who's where'd you text me
do you have her number
[Laughter]
no man hard to tell you to me in a way I
want to shave her tits a little bit but
dude the Bucky character the [ __ ] guy
at the counter oven your and the tacos
good no I know what you want big boy
thanks brother let's get back into it
cat what do you think about this [ __ ]
sick twisted man who's calling oh no no
no I don't think I could do it
personally but that's if she's 22 she's
probably just getting into this so you
got a couple more years where we got to
figure this out if you're trying to
stick with her it takes a mature dude to
deal with this but also there's there's
such a taboo on porno stars and
strippers and stuff I don't see the big
deal with it I don't see the big deal
with that at all well she strippers
right what is he asking yeah yeah see I
think these ask me if you guys could do
it like you come over help with the
fight son cuz that stresses me out dude
really I mean if they want to play like
a pickup game I'm down I don't know what
they're trying to do though yeah I don't
know I would rather I don't think I want
to do that have you ever dated a porno
star I've like been interested in it um
yeah I probably definitely like stalked
a couple of them yeah yeah you know but
I don't think there's anything wrong
with porno stars or anything like that I
just think could you date one though do
deal with like I don't know I think it
would be too much sometimes the culture
is just the the something that I
one around you know like I remember uh
it's not a terrible idea I had a
roommate whose friend was a stripper and
she stole our vacuum once and so it's
just like telling you got all this you
know you got a lot of extras there's a
lot of baggage that comes along with
this type of person the same as like
dating a comedian or something I think
there's a lot of like you know there's a
lot of bag as it comes along with these
people
everybody wants a pit bull - you get a
pit bull yeah a lot of responsibility
yeah till it eats one of the twins you
know and you're like damn bro you know
where's Lenny yeah you asked for it
so I think that get a pit bull I think
that the 32 and 22 also seems a little
tough sometimes 22 like you have a like
a partner in crime as opposed to like an
associate or somebody that you kind of
reign over a little bit but that could
just be me being judgmental as well I
mean here's the other thing you got to
question yourself if you're if you're if
you got a connection with a 22 year old
porn star yeah I'm saying they guess you
might have to question what's going on
yeah maybe
oh dude I've met some porno stars blow
your mind not only in the bedroom but
also you know the super smart like I
said Karen do you know her yeah she's
really really creative yet in every way
yeah and a lot of them are not though a
lot of them belongs typical you know
glory hole girls yeah some people can't
read and they're all just out there
[ __ ] people online mm-hmm
so anyway bro good luck yeah listen
takes a special tie listen yeah I had a
friend who was an open relationship I
told him dude you're a special special
type of dude to live that life and you
stressed out all the time I don't know
man I don't know how that issue baby be
feeling erect bro oh it's higher dudes
no sweat well a lot of times when a lot
of blood goes into my wiener you get
tired I get tired yeah big dick leaves
my brain I think but ya must shut down
I'm not a sprawl come to and I'll just
be you know pretending like I'm [ __ ]
most that blood goes to your ass I'm
head
you got that dumper right back there I
gotta remind you I did you didn't even
know how to nice I asked you piece of
[ __ ] buddy it's nice to be friends dude
I know I will you always hide it dude
like we mean dude get the cake cake cake
cakes out your disgusting brother who
Orleans cakes out this ain't an IHOP
brother you better get on here's what
I'm saying this guy if you can do it
cheers to you man I better man than me
yeah it sound like there's some bravado
winning you know you wanted to tell us
you got these threesomes foursomes
fivesome
dude it's all fun and games so half your
[ __ ] goes missing right you know what
I'm saying
there's no way five people are over at
your house just to [ __ ] not steal
something all right
every dude I go over to somebody's house
bro even if I'm in love with them I
might steal some [ __ ] yeah I'll go
through their cabinets then you see
what's up you know many seen how much
silverware I have from rich people off
[ __ ] houses I went over to growing up
how many medications I have now look at
about 70 sets brah preach
I always steal from the out backstage
but look also in another part of me is
envious oh you out there you getting it
you got that you know you got the
titties and all of that and the glitter
and everybody you bust her nuts yeah you
bust a name yes we got what do you think
Dee well I think you deal with it figure
girls a porn star I mean she seems cool
about it
he described this awesome girl and he
was being way more of a ho about it than
the porn star well she's a porn star so
what else she can bring in the day yeah
that's all she [ __ ] dude it's her job
bro yeah yeah and it's her job mo bro
you should make more money than you shut
the [ __ ] up you don't know you'd be
surprised how much little money they
don't make any they gotta own all their
[ __ ] that's like James then flip the
script that's what they all do the mic
and stuff now yeah they all did the it's
so sad those women all been taking
advantage of everything that's sports
that's everything so yeah there's no
difference we in porno stars and UFC
fighters oh I only one person making all
the money
I agree Conor McGregor oh you know what
you're all doing work everybody gets
concussed with a dick to the face or
elbow
you're all getting can cause porno stars
and fighters bro
I don't know it's science let's move on
is it science when Britain's has it
science I think he's got a Google
science here here one thing y'all will
comment on this a little bit further
because he did ask he said would you be
able to handle it I don't think I would
be able to land handle it I don't think
I would be able to handle it if it's a
girl that I'm really into if it's a girl
you're just hooking up with porn stars
90 out of six seven 95 times it's been
it's there where they're supposed to be
their best it's better seen than not
hurt or whatever it is you know
sometimes it'll bump me out when you
meet them yeah it's always it's it's
it's the lights the camera the action
you know you never want you never want
to meet your heroes brother it's true
man really is true you don't want to see
how sausage is made
yeah and then you get thing like oh this
what they do yes what they do Playboy we
had a pig that was misbehaving a lot of
times when we'd take him over there
about a sausage maker and show him what
the [ __ ] was gonna happen boy [ __ ] yeah
you [ __ ] look over there Darius
forget it Darius baby back ribs located
a little bell on his neck barbecue sauce
I was like an Asian belle yeah man damn
there he is calm down over there he was
always [ __ ] local bro dude film that
buy some see what's up dude's a minute
next week yeah bro get some fireballs
dude get some lasers out of here you
could shoot a laser out of your ass bro
and [ __ ] take down a stop sign in a
small town but I'm doing it I'll give
you $40 boy
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
you